previously on Ava bridged Tokyo is
currently under monster attack ten
thousand 572 everyone panic the ages are
attacking Humanity is in danger your
dad's waiting for you oh my god
individual oh my god it's Godzilla oh my
god
it's Godzilla as usual we the Japanese
military are useless [ __ ] ducks don't
worry everyone Shinji Ikari is here to
save the day
Shinji who are the manliest hero I've
ever seen and I've absolutely attracted
to you so you are definitely not a [ __ ]
any news new 22 metaphase Venus go up to
the particle space continuum that makes
perfect sense
although this was my finishing move
angel assessment destroy much injuries
awesome no gingy is your living father
who is always proud of you I have one
last thing to say yes daddy dearest wha
what just happened
so let me get this straight Jimmy calls
him last night all 70 billion dollars
worth of collateral damage you're
[ __ ] me nope that's what we get for
protecting millions of people living
here this bright idea wasn't to build a
city with millions of people on top of
the world's most dangerous and secretive
military base I'm a [ __ ] genius
no one opposed this idea there was one
he's a [ __ ] idiot well what am I so
bad if the pilot did a better job you
mean humanity's last hope who passed out
in peed his pants
you mean humanity's last hope who just
woke us gingy's awake is he all right
this arm is stalking me he's perfectly
fine well he's still a kid someone's
gonna have to take care of him not it
not it in it so I've sorted it out with
the higher-ups shinji's gonna be staying
with you rates go are you seriously
making me babysit a fourteen-year-old
boy I thought you'd like it
just don't go seducing him or anything
ha ha very funny it was a joke he saw -
where's your sense of humor oh so you
don't think I've a sense of humor do you
all right then here's a job for you come
on
knock-knock go [ __ ] yourself seducing
young boys that woman doesn't know what
she's talking about
Shinji you're coming in me tonight I
mean I'm coming with you
right I know what I said that wasn't a
very nice joke you told dr. a cocky it's
just a joke between friends Shinji tell
it to your friends I bet they will find
it really funny so you and dr. ACOG your
friends [ __ ] pretty much Sammy Sado
there's one thing I've been wondering
ever since I've joined nerve yeah Shinji
what is nerve actually stand for no
one's told you yet oh well I'm pretty
sure it stands for nervous erection
reaches vagina I'm sorry son and that's
how I lost my virginity uh I'm not even
gonna ask well here we are
home sweet home welcome to your new
house
Misato
is there anything slightly edible to
find everything you need in the fridge
booze booze and booze let a glass of
whiskey um you saw it oh I'm only 14
just a beer then no that means I'm a
minor
oh don't be such a [ __ ] Shinji drink up
it's against the law me Sato I'll have a
beer so as you can see unit zero is
currently system holy [ __ ] it's a blonde
I mean you're dumb and [ __ ] uh sir I'm
head scientist here at nerd what kind of
idiot hired a blonde is that scientist
you did I what sir it's me rich Scola
cocky
oh my bad my bad all you blondes look
the same you really are an [ __ ] you
know that sir are you asking me out on a
date what rate I'll pick you up at 7:00
my total and I never to flirt later dr.
ACOG E right now an important work to do
Oh as I was saying sir unit zero is
currently TSA's holy [ __ ] it's a blonde
I mean you're dumb and [ __ ] huh really
hope that we saw is having better luck
babysitting can you please stop bitching
about your ex-boyfriend already
I'm sorry mr. stud let's hear about your
gray relationship history whoa uh yeah
it doesn't count damn it well at least I
don't have a drinking problem
your face has a drinking problem it's
Otto you're drunk your face is drunk
sotto what you're an ignoramus your face
is it a day
that's no what I even up should you get
no goddamn bat
he's ro if I'm will yo get on the floor
clean up on our one
jeez how often does a kid jerk off
Shinji I'm opening the door listen
things might be confusing now but I just
want you to know that everything you did
today was a good thing look once you
start school tomorrow you'll realize all
the good piloting the AVA is done
alright and that's for piloting a stupid
robot what did I do
you destroyed half my neighborhood and
put a sister in the hospital that's
right and wait what oh and that's for
destroying half my neighborhood and
putting my sister in the hospital I'm
pretty sure he calls your mom fat - what
no I did it oh sorry about - jeez give
me a little cranky sometimes when we
stand up as if it was punching bag he
said your haircut looks unbelievably
homo oh so we have a smartass here
alright new kids you got anything else
smart to say to me go see your friends I
bet they don't find it really funny
seto gee yes knocks knocks so that
shitty kids the new pilot of the AVA huh
ah did you know that the AVA is equipped
with a giant m34 minigun as its main
shut up no Georgie you gotta hear this
hey Kent skate remember when I said that
I was pretty desperate for the toilet
mm-hmm I told you once that I get P shy
around people mmm so why the hell are
you standing right next to me when I'm
trying to take a pass because it's
easier to talk don't look at me don't
speak to me
don't breathe my air not a [ __ ] word
I can see your wiener oh my god so I
heard Shinji got punched by a fellow
classmate and you're telling me this
because you didn't tell him anything
that could provoke other people did you
why would you think that hey ray
knock-knock oh come on it was a joke and
I thought Shinji was the child speaking
of which how'd your date with the
commander go do you really have to ask
have sex with me
I'm sex with me have sex with me have
sex with me please
fine yes luckily the bullet just grazed
my arm tough break sometimes I wonder
how this organization is relevant
worried even the commander takes orders
from the top brass in the UN I'm sure
they're coming up with a plan we can't
even begin to imagine we are birds I
Robot
I ain't robot good I like giant robot oh
my God my hands are glued to my face
again gentlemen if we could get back on
track please as I was saying mr. Ducati
can you explain your thinking behind
giving a multi-billion dollar robot to
your fat holding to have and destroy a
fascicle you Sookie did it irrelevant
just remember for now to the true
objective I'd say lay is the completion
of the human instrumentality project the
human instrument what now the human
instrumentality project you've lost me
this this document we've been discussing
for the past hour
oh this thing right no idea what you're
looking at no I do not enough it seems
like the fourth angel has arrived mr.
Ikari you know what to do of course I do
I just have one question
what's an angel object detected it's Oh
fine run an analysis and change all our
levels to read where shinty running away
come on get him back now analysis bad
and confirmed blue it's an angel it's an
angel hmm
it's big it's a Gundam you all shut up
look at it everyone knows it's a
freaking angel we need to be a buzzkill
Masato yeah we were just trying to have
a bit of fun you'd be a lot cooler if
you just joined in we are in the middle
of a red level our girl bisoder got a
rocket I can't have any fun cuz I was
ever stick-up is fine fine if you'll get
you all the shop I'll do it hmm it's
angels bruh total three alpha team is
currently engaging the enemy know we
need orders now you mother [ __ ] I saw
him we don't have time for this ah all
right what's the status of the missing
pilot wait don't make me go back
while it's secure okay macoco can you
need a prep assistant for a table on
shot at eb key contact Delta team and
tell them to be on standby Roger alpha
team I need a location photo what the
hell was that I believe that was the
status report okay know what it was you
know what forget it
gingy are you ready to launch no really
what David has reached the surface
okay shinty we need you carefully aim
for the heart keep home huh straight
gingy is currently pleading the angel
attack the civilian center has anyone
seen where to Jean Ken's gay have gone I
think they went outside a while ago when
on earth could they still be doing just
how long can you pay for but I was just
about to get to the Ava's armor specs
alright screw this I'm gonna pee outside
wait
touji you really shouldn't be going
outside you shut up give me one good
reason I shouldn't go outside right now
since she's classmates what the hell are
they doing here I just wanted to be we
can't get civilians involved in this
battle we have to retreat Jesus oh right
yeah now she talking to us
oh I'm talking to those trees right
beside you I recommend we go with
evacuation plan B agreed
Delta team I need you to provide
covering fire can you make it in time
Kovu proposal to roll over the sugar Oh
what's the ETA for reinforcements oh
don't open eleven our code we have to
get them out of there now
run away JJ I know I told you you don't
have to run away anymore but we need
oh [ __ ] everything even power cables and
cuts with 37 rubber a still time left
okay we're all gonna die second hey new
kids you mind if I take a week in here
humanity is dying and all I can think
about is how I don't give a [ __ ] you
need to take charge of everyone get off
my ass for what like at negative 47 Bob
can someone please tell me what's going
on I have a bonus and second everyone
second destroyed everyone ready your
battle stations
boy you Sookie fetch me my victory
sandwich I finally know what an angel is
what'd I miss
I'll do
Oh